اهلا بكم الى تغطياتنا الموسعه المستمره
والعاجله كذلك للاحداث في السودان التي
يعيش صراعا مستمرا تجعل السودانيين امام
مفترق طرق في الايام القادمه
اذا خامس ايام النزاع المسلحه في السودان
يامن مدخمه بالرصاص والقصف المتبادل بين
قوات الجيش من جهه وقوات الدعم السريع من
جهه اخرى هدنه اصبحت من الماضي بعد خروقات
مستمره من الطرفين
174 مدنيا على الاقل راحوا ضحيه المواجهات
وفقا لنقابه اطباء السودان فضلا عن 1041
مصابا في احصائيات تتزايد مع مرور ساعات
الجيش السوداني اعلن اليوم التصدي لهجوم
جديد على محيط القاعده العامه او القياده
العامه وجددت دعوه ايضا لافراد الدعم
السريع لتسليم انفسهم لاقرب وحده عسكريه
واندلعت حرائق هائله في محيط مبنى القياده
العامه للجيش مطار الخرطوم صباح اليوم
جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم كذلك تحدث شهود عيان عن استهداف
خزانات وقود داخل
مطار الخرطوم الذي تتصاعد منه الادخنه
الكثيفه وتستمر الاشتباكات بين الطرفين في
السودان منذ خمسه ايام رغم موافقه قوات
الدعم السريعه على مقترح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
بعقد هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لمده 40 ساعه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي خالد الفك سيد خالد مرحبا بك معي
اليوم الخامس اذن
للمواجهات والعمليات العسكريه والاشتباكات
المستمره في العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا هل
يمكن الحديث عن
تشكل الملامح من هذه العمليات العسكريه
ومن تميل لصالحه كفه هذه المواجهات حتى
اليوم الخامس يبدا
هو مسده الاكبر وعنوانه الكبير مزيد من
الدماء ومزيدا من رائحه البارود ومزيد من
السحب التي تغطي
السوداء التي تغطي سماء
خاصه
الاحياء الاحياء الشرقيه لولايه الخرطوم
فبالتالي يبدو ان اليوم هو مختلف تماما
يوم يعني لا نستطيع ان نقول من الذي يحسم
ولكن من خلال المعلومات الاوليه التي تدور
ان الدعم السريعي غالي هجومين على القياده
العامه ومنذ الساعات الفجري الاولى شاهدنا
الطيران الحربي يحلق وشهدنا الدخان يتصاعد
بكثافه من محيط القياده مما يعني ان الدعم
السريه الان هو
القوات المسلحه متابعه فبالتالي الان ربما
على حسب المعلومات الاوليه ان القوات
المسلحه استطاعت الى حد كبير صب هذا
الهجوم
ودحره ولكن تبقى ما زالت هناك الجيوب
للدعم السريع في حاله وفرق ويعيد تنظيم
صفوفه في كل فتره وكل مرحله كل مره
وصديق من موقع استراتيجي اعاده ترتيب
صفوفه وعدم مجددا مما يشكل عقبه في
استكمال مقاله عن القوات المسلحه انها
بصدره وهي عمليات التمشيط وعمليه بسط
الامني في ولايه الخرطوم ولكن يبدو ان
الدعم السالبيه الكثير من القوه وما زال
يستخدم عدد من التكتيكات وهي الكروه الفرد
التي يمكن ان ترهق القوات المسلحه
ومنسوبيها في ظل يعني ما يعرف في حرب حرب
المدن التي قد ترجح قصه الدعم السريع لانه
هو معروف عنها خفه الحركه
وخلفه التسليح وتعدد التسليح ما بين
المتوسط والخفيف والثقيل فبالتالي اعتقد
ان اليوم هذا سيكون ساخن وصعيب جدا على
السودانيين الذين هم الان هم قالوا في
منازلهم يرابطون في ظل يعني نقصي والحرب
الان تدخل اليوم الخامس بدات الحوجه ماسه
لاسريعه الاستهلاكيه الرئيسيه هناك
اشكاليات تتعلق بالنقص المياه الصالحه
للشربي بعد ان قال الجيش ان الدعم السريع
يعني اعتدى وضرب
يعني مناطق خزانات المياه الرئيسيه ايضا
هناك اشكاليات في الكهرباء والكهرباء او
اداره الكهرباء حذرت وقالت ان
السودان هو الان على وشك الاطفاء التام
اذن استاذ خالد على المشهد الامني
والانساني في ظل عدم انفراج السياسيه او
اي مبادره يمكن ان تحكم الدماء والموقدا
وتجعل الجميع في فتره جديده
انسانيا ايضا كيف استطاع السودانيون يعني
الاستفاده والتحرك خلال ساعات الهدنه هذه
الهدنه الهشه التي شهدت ايضا اشتباكات
متقطعه ربما في اكثر من مكان
لاحظوا شيء قبل قليل كنت في في جوله قريبه
[موسيقى]
المياه والكهرباء اعتقد انه يجعل
السودانيين
امام تحدي كبير
والعالم الاسلامي والعربي يستقبل الايام
العيد فاذا يعيدني يعيدها والسودان في
يعني ما يمكن ان يصب الايام السوداء
الايام التي مليئه بالدماء هناك يعني وفق
المصادر اليها ما زال هناك جثث يعني يصعب
الوصول اليها لنقلها الى المسارح او
مهاراتها ما زال هناك عدد من الضحايا
او جماعه لمزيد من الدماء
لعلاج الجرح الذي نحتاجون لنقل دم ما زالت
هناك في ظل خروج نحو 40 مستشفى من الخدمه
وتعرض اكبر اكبر مستشفين في
العاصمه من قلبي الاحداث تحديدا القياده
العامه نصفي كيلومتر الى غزف مباشر وصغوط
دانات واسلحه صغيره يعني جعلت هذا الامر
يخرج تلك المستشفيين من دائره الخدمه
الطبيه والصحيه اذا الوضع الانساني هو
يعني كارثي ويحتاج الى تدخلات عاجله من
المجتمع الاقليمي والدوري الان هناك اسر
في السودان قد لا تستطيع الحصول على وقود
يومها
بدايه الاسر التي ظلت حديثه في محيط
الاحداث سواء كان في احياء مثل مثل
الرياض مثل
الطائف مثل
حي الصفا مثل العمارات نمره ثلاثه هذه هذه
هذه هذه الاحياء كلها يعني تكاتك يعني
حديثه في منازلها
لاربعه وخمسه ايام في نفس في ظل نقص
السلعه الرئيسيه
ونقصتنا اليه من الحوجه اساسيه
سيد خالد يريد فقط ان يشير هنا الى
الاخبار العاجله الذي تريدون اتباعا
حول من الدعم السريع الذي يكون من الجيش
يحرك قوات عسكريه ومجموعات مسلحه من مختلف
المدن الى الخرطوم وانه يشن ايضا هجمات
باسلحه ثقيله على مواقع تمركزي قواتنا
وتسبب في مقتل المدني
هذا حقنا الان الى القياده العامه تم
السيطره
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي الجهود الاقليميه للتهدئه تلقى وزير
الخارجات السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اتصالا من نظيرها الامريكي انتن بلينك ان
تركز على الاوضاع في السودان واكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وبلينكن خلال الاتصال على
اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكريه في السودان
وضروره حمايه المدنيين والاجانب وشددها
على اهميه امن واستقرار السودان قبل ذلك
وفي ذات السياقه كاد وزير الخارجات المصري
سامح شكري ان بلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع
الاطراف السن السودانيات المتنازعه من اجل
استئناف الحوار السلمي لتسويه الوضع
بينهما وجدد شكرياتاكيد على ضروره امتناع
جميع اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ الاجانب عن
تصعيد الوضع في السودان معبرا عن امله في
التوصل الى حل قريب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
نعيد التذكير ايضا بما كشفته مصادر خاصه
للعربيه عن تحركات مصريه اقليميه تشمل
دخول مراقبين
للوصول الى وقف ليطلق النار خلال عيد
الفطر فتح ممرات امنه بين مصر والسودان
لمده 48 ساعه لسماح بنقل المصابين ودخول
المساعدات الانسانيه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
لجنه امميه دوليه وتسهيل دخولها للاشراف
على كافه الاسراء من الجانبين وتسهيل مهام
بعثات الامم المتحده وبرامج الغذاء
العالمي من خلال التعيين قوه خاصه لتامين
مهامهم داخل الاراضي السودانيه المصادر
كشفت ايضا عن وجود مشاورات حول تشكيل
اللجنه دوليه محايدا مسؤوله عن التحقيق في
الاحداث الحنيه في السودان ولذلك اكدت
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جانبير
انه لا يوجد لدى الاداره الامريكيه اي خطط
لعمليات اجلاء من السودان وسط تواصل اطلاق
النار بكثافه في الخرطوم
لا خطط حاليا لعمليات اجلاء من السودان
برعايه امريكيه مع تواصل اطلاق النار في
الخرطوم رغم بدع سريان الهدنه ادعو جميع
الامريكيين في السودان التحسن بمكان امن
القاهره تنضم الينا اسماء الحسين مدير
التحرير صحيفه الاهرام والمختصه في الشؤون
الافريقيه السيده اسماء الحسينيه اولا
لماذا حتى الان لم تنجح كل الاطراف في
تحقيق اي اختراق في جدار هذه الازمه في
ايقاف حلقه العنف والمواجهات والاشتباكات
بين السوداني
ياتي ذلك بسبب يعني هذه المعركه المحمومه
التي يخوضها الطرفان
ويعتبرانها معركه وجود وحياه كل طرف يرى
ان وجوده مرتبط بانتصاره في هذه المعركه
ومن هنا تاتي المعارك المحتدمه كل طرف
يريد ان يطيح بالطرف الاخر ويزيح من
المشهد
ويعتقد انه اي تهاون في هذه المعركه او
الاستجابه
لوقف اطلاق نار مؤقت او هدنه مؤقته هو
يتيح للطرف الاخر ترتيب اوراقه يتيح له
اعاده ترتيب اوضاعه والتقدم وهذا هو ما
حدث كان هناك عدم ثقه بين الطرفين اراد كل
منهم ان يظهر للمجتمع الدولي اللي مارس
ضغوط قويه جدا عبر الاتصال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وبالطبع بالترتيب مع حلفائه في
المنطقه
يعني كلهم حاول ان يظهر امام المجتمع
الدولي انه سيلتزم بالهدنه ولكن في حقيقه
الامر كل كان غير يعني يعني يعني
واثق من ان هذه الهدنه سيلتزم بها الطرف
الاخر ويطالب الولايات المتحده بان يلتزم
الطرف الاخر حاولوا تبيض وجوههم امام
المجتمع الدولي وكانهم هم الاطراف الحريصه
لكن في واقع الامر حرصهم على تعزيز
مواقعهم على الارض كان اكبر وكان ايضا
هناك شحن كبير جدا
داخل كل معسكر بان الطرف الاخر سيستهدفه
خلال هذه الهدنه وكانه حياه ملايين البشر
في السودان لا قيمه لها ولا يجب اعطائها
حتى فرصه
لانقاذ اوضاعها ضوء هذه الاوضاع هذه
الاشتباكات
يعني هذه الحرب بين قوات الدعم السريع
وكذلك الجيش هل من مجال
عندما يتم الحديث عن تحركات مصريه اقليميه
لدخول مراقبين دوليين للوصول الى وقف
لاطلاق النار خلال عيد الفطر هل يمكن ان
يكتب لهذه الجهود اي نجاحنا
نعم مصر تسعى الان من اجل تحقيق هذه
الخطوات التي هي خطوات ضروريه للغايه من
اجل انقاذ واغاثه ملايين البشر المحاصرين
الان بسبب هذه الحرب واعتقد انه انها تقود
تنسيق واسع جدا مع كل الاطراف يعني
اقليميه ودوليه اتصالات بالامم المتحده
بالولايات المتحده بالقوه العربيه
بالاتحاد الافريقي
واعتقد انه ما تطرحه مصر الان هو ضروري
ويجب ان تتضافر مع كل الجهود الدوليه من
اجل انجاحه لن يكون ذلك بدون ضغوط دوليه
مكثفه من جميع هذه الاطراف مجتمعه
والضغط المكثف والرسائل الواضحه الجليه
لكلا الطرفين المتحاربين بانهما مهددين
بالعقوبات وبالملاحقه من قبل المجتمع
الدولي وان هذه هي من اجل التهدئه ومن اجل
التوجه الى حل هي فرصه لهما لانقاذ وضعهما
ايضا لانه هم ادخلوا البلد في ورطه لكنهما
ايضا في حقيقه الوضع كل منهما في ورطه حتى
اي منهم لن يستطيع ازاحه الطرف الاخر
بالاجماع وبالاجمال ولن حتى اذا انتصر لن
تكتب له يكتب له ترتيب اوضاعه او
الاستقرار كما يريد او تحقيق ما يريد من
بقاء في السلطه لانه سيكون مواجه بالمجتمع
الدولي وبالداخل السوداني ايضا لانه في
السودان اطراف متعدده وكل لها مطالب كبيره
من اجل تحول مدني ديموقراطي ومن اجل حياه
كريمه ومن اجل ايضا توحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه
وتطويرها وابعادها العدسيه ممكن فعليا
اليوم يعني ونحن نشاهد الان لسنه الدخان
التي تستمر
ايضا في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم الحديث كذلك
عن اشتباكات عنيفه جدا في مقر القياده
العامه وفي محيط مقر القياده العامه بمحيط
القصر الجمهوري في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه
الخرطوم تحركات ايضا
وتبادل الاتهامات واللغه العنيفه بين
الطرفين الصراع كل ذلك يعني اذا ما نظرنا
اليه هل يمكن ان يساهم بالفعل في اي
تحركات من اي اطراف يعني في انجاح اي
تحركات من اي اطراف الان
يعني بالفعل الوضع خطير للغايه وكل طرف
يعني مصره على ان يمضي حتى نهايه الشوط في
محاربه الطرف الاخر
وفي تاجيج فعلا عبر يعني خطابات كراهيه
وخطابات عنصريه وخطابات تحرض على استمرار
القتال لكن اعتقد ان نجاح هذه المبادرات
التي يتم عنها الحديث عنها دوليه واقليميه
سيكون
رهين بمدى الضغوط التي يمكن ان تمارس على
الاطراف الان هناك تلويح في واشنطن من قبل
المشرعين في الكونجرس بعقوبات فرديه على
قاده الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
المتورطين في تاجيل الحرب اعتقد ان مثل
هذه هذه
الخطابات هي مطلوبه في المرحله الراهنه من
اجل مواجهه الطرفين بما يمكن ان يترتب على
من نتائج افعالهم وما سيصيبهم هم شخصيا
قاده وما سيصيب الوضع برمته في السودان
والرساله يجب ان تكون واضحه ايضا بان الحل
العسكري غير مقبول وان ما يترتب عليه لن
يتم الاعتراف به من قبل المجتمع الدولي
هناك حاجه لضغوط مكثفه مجمعه
متكاتفه من قبل الاطراف جميعا في الاقليم
والعالم من اجل تحقيق هذا الهدف شكرا
جزيلا لك يا اسماء الحسين مدير التحرير
صحيفه الايران ومختصه في شؤون الافريقيه
الدعم السريع
مطر بدون برك هنا مطرنا بدون سحاب
سلاح النقلي
الفرقه الرابعه مشاهده اسود النيل الازرق
مطر بدون براك كويس لان مطر بدون سحاب عدل
ولسه
اجداد بنجيب شاي
وعرض لكم
[موسيقى]
انتهت فكت منكم
السعوديه السعوديه
كان زمان
السميري بس
[موسيقى]
لامه على رسول الله سيدنا محمد عليه افضل
الصلاه الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
عربيه
بكامل عتادها
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لذلك تعلن زياده
الفرقه
وفي سياق تطورات الاوضاع الصحيه الصعبه في
السودان دارت منظمه الصحه العالميه بشده
الهجمات التي تعرض لها الموظفون الصحيون
والمرافق الصحيه والسيارات الاسعاف وقالت
المنظمه في بيان ان هذه الاجابات اخذت في
الازدياد وتسببت في مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص على
الاقل واصابه اثنين اخرين واشارت المنظمه
الى ان هذه الهجمات تحد من امكانيه حصول
المواطنين على الرعايه اللازمه الامر الذي
يعرض المزيد من الارواح للخطر وعبرت منظمه
الصحه العالميه عن قلقها اثر التقارير
التي تحدثت عن ضرب المرافق الصحيه ونهبها
واختطاف سيارات الاسعاف ولفتت منظمه الصحه
الى ان الهجمات على العاملين والمنشات
الصحيه انتهاك صارخ للقانون الدولي مطالبه
جميع الاطراف بضمان الوصول الامن للمرضى
والعاملين الى المستشفيات وبدورها راعت
اودعت وزاره الصحه السودانيه
لايقاف العمليات المسلحه التي طالت
المرافق الصحيه في ولايه الخرطوم وادت الى
خروج سته عشر مستشفى عن الخدمه فضلا عن
صعوبه وصول الكوادر الصحيه والاطباء الى
المستشفيات وعدم تمكن سيارات الاسعاف من
اداء مهامه وزير الصحه هيثم ابراهيم اشار
الى ان القطاع الصحي سيعاني من اثار
كارثيه اضافه او اضافيه مع اطاله امد
الصراع
ايضا نائب رئيس نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
علي بشير في تصريحاته للعربيه بضروره
توفير ممرات امنه لنقل واخلاء المرضى
مؤكده ان الوضع الطبي اخذ فلانهيار
حقيقه وضع الانسان وضع كارهي
والنظام الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول انه
بنهار تماما في ظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات
للقصف المباشر وخروجها عن الخدمه
واخرها مستشفى فضيل الذي تعرض
بالاسلحه الثقيله مما ادى الى سقط في
القائد المركزي وصهاري المياه الرئيسيه
والمخصصه لمرضى غسيل الكلى كما ان هنالك
عدد كبير من المستشفيات محدد بالخروج عن
الخدمه نتيجه لشح
الوقود المطالب الاكثر الحاحا هي الالتزام
بالهدنه والعمل على الوقفه الدائم لاطلاق
النار وقف هذه الحرب العاطفيه
كما نطالب بفتح مسارات امنه وتحديدها
وتامينها من قبل هذه القوات المتقاتله
لا يتسع المكان هنا
تشفيات تكاد تفيض بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا
مستلزمات فيها ربما ولا حتى اكسجين
الحرج لم يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه
غسل طارئه لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في
الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قداءف عشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قدائف العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من اكبر
مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمه مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر دعوات حقوقيه لوقف
اطلاق النار لفتح مسارات امنه لنقل
المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيين وان تحققت
لفتره فثمت تحولات عسكريه بين حين واخر قد
تجعل الحاله اكثر ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
نذهب الى الخرطوم الى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك الان ما اخر ما تم
رصده من تطورات سالم خصوصا من حيث المعارك
المحتدمه في محيط القصر الجمهوري وكذلك في
محيط مقر القياده العامه
المشاهدين العديد من المعارك التي بدات
منذ فجر اليوم منذ الرابعه فجرا وما زلت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظات
في مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم وبحري
هذه المناطق تشهد
بسباكات التي كانت
انواع الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه كذلك
مضادات الطائرات اضافه الى سلاح الجو
السوداني كذلك
وبالاضافه الى الاسلحه الاخرى الثقيله
والخفيفه والتي شكلت لدى المواطنين واصوات
كانت مزعجه بالنسبه للقنابل والدانات التي
تسقط اثناء فتره هذه الاشتباكات في
المناطق المتفرقه في الخرطوم
يتفرقت هذه الاشتباكات في عدد من المناطق
ابرزها محيط القياده العامه للجيش وكذلك
في منطقه جبر كذلك كان هناك اشتباك محتدم
وايضا في شارع الغابه في الجريف
وبري كذلك والمناطق التي بالقرب من شارع
الستين كذلك كانت هناك اشتباكات كل هذه
المناطق شهيده العديد من الاشتباكات بين
قوات الدعم السريع جاء بعد ذلك بيان الجيش
السوداني الذي اكد فيه ان الجيش السوداني
نفذ هجمات على
المنتفلسطين والمتمردين وكبدهم خسائر
فادحه
واكد ايضا الجيش السوداني في هذا السياق
انه يدعو بقيه ويدعو قوات الدعم السريع من
افرادها يجدد لهم الدعوه لتسليم انفسهم
لاقرب وحده عسكريه للقياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه كذلك تحدث عن انه
تصدى لهجوم جديد على محيط القياده العامه
من قوات الدعم السريع هذا هو الابرز حتى
الان جاء بعد ذلك ايضا نعم مساله المساله
المتعلقه بقوات الدعم السريعه التي ذكرت
فيها ان الجيش السوداني تعدى على هذه
الهدنه وهو سبب انتهاك هذه الهدنه وهذه
ليست المره الاولى التي يتبادل فيها
الطرفان الاتهامات بشان الغده هذه هي
الهدنه الثالث ه التي يفشل الطرفين في
انزالها على ارض الواقع
الانساني والتطوراتها ايضا سالم
بالنسبه للوضع الانساني هناك اشكاليات
وهناك نداءات ترفع من هنا ومن هناك لكن
ابرزها واخرها وهو المتعلق بالمستشفيات
المستشفيات تعاني من مشكلات كثيره جدا لكن
نقابه اطباء السودان
ذكرت انه توقف 39 مستشفى من اصل 59 في
العاصمه تسعه مستشفيات تعرضت بقص و16
تعرضت لاخلاء والقوات العسكريه تعتدي على
خمس سيارات اسعاف وتمنعها من المرور
والمستشفيات العامله مخدده الاغلاق لنقص
المعينات هذه هي طبعا الكارثه الصحيه التي
تحدثت عنها وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه بالامس
وهي تحذر من وضع كارثه صحي اذا لم يتم
تدارك هذا الموضوع خاصه في الولايات
الخرطوم في هذه
الازمه ومنذ اندلاعها لان هناك العديد من
المستش خرجت عن الخدمه العديد من
المستشفيات ما زالت تعاني من نقص في
المعينات ستعاني من نقص الكوارث الطبيه
عدم قدره القاده للوصول الى المستشفى نقص
في المياه كذلك الكهربائي كل هذه التفاصيل
تجعل العديد من المستشفيات تخرج من الخدمه
وهذا امر خطير للغايه هناك مستشفيات
اخلوها
قسريا كما ذكرت نقابه الاطباء لانه اضطروا
الى الخروج من المستشفى مثل المستشفى جعفر
بن عوف هذا المستشفى من اكبر المستشفيات
الاطفال في السودان وهو في شارع المكنبه
لا يبعد كثيرا عن الصوره التي تراها على
الشاشه على القياده العامه لا يبعد كثيرا
من هذا الطريق هذا المستشفى خرج المرضى من
المستشفى
واضطروا للخروج لانهم يسمعون اصوات القصف
والرصاص
يعني اخلوا المستشفى لعدم امان المستشفى
كل هذه الامور تجعل الوضع الصحي بكارثه
اذا لم يتم التدخل
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه
من الخرطوم اذكر ايضا باخر التطورات اخر
الاخبار العاجله تاتي من السوشيد بريس
التي تفيد بارتفاع ضد قطر المواجهات في
السودان الى 270 شخصا على الاقل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المعارك القائمه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه عده سيناريوهات على
مستقبل السودان منها
سيريوهات قادمه متابعه
انفجار هائل وسط الخرطوم دخان اسود كثيف
يصنع مشهدا قاتما للسودان احتمالاته هي ان
يفوز البرهان في المعركه وتنشق جماعه
حميتي ان يفوز حميدتي ويتبعثر الجيش وتدخل
البلاد حربا اهليه نزاع يستمر لسنوات طوال
بين لا غالب ولا مغلوب يصطلح الطرفان
ويقتسمان الصلاحيات وهو سيناريو الذي
يتمناه السوداني
السودانيين هم منظف قلوبنا جميعا
الحسد من الحسد من الحقد
قد تحسم المعركه عسكريا في بعض المناطق في
السودان لكن الصراع قد يطول بسبب
التقسيمات القبليه والسياسيه لكلا الطرفين
المتنازعين هذا معناه اننا امام مرحله من
الصراع الطبيب الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحو لفتره اطول
مما هو يعني يبدو السيناريو الذي يرجوه
السودانيون هو المصالحه يلتقي حميدتي
والبرهان ويتفقان على دمج قوه الدعم
السريع مع القوات المسلحه ليكون للسودان
جيش واحد يحفظ الامن ويلبي امنيات هذا
الطفل الصغير
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
الخرطوم ايضا نعود الى الصحافه والمحرر
السياسي خالد الفكي السيد خالد في قراءه
او او تحليل ربما لهذه السيناريوهات دعنا
نبدا من الاخير
المصالحه هل هي وارده بعد هذه اللغه
العنيفه بعد هذه المواجهات بعد هذه
المواقف من طرفي اسرع ام ان يعني الامور
وصلت الى نقطه لا عوده بين حميد والبرهان
نعم صحيح يعني واضح جدا ان الطرفين وصل
نقطه لا عوده وذلك من خلال تمسكهم بلغه
الحوار بلغه البندقيه وعدم الاستجابه
لدعوات الحوار فكان ما يبدو هذا يعني
ويدري من معارك كانه هو مالك الشخصيه بين
البرهان وليس بين
مؤسستين عسكريتين الدعم السري والجيش
والجيش فبالتالي اعتقد ان اي حديث عن
مصالحه في الوقت الراهن بين الرجلين يعني
قد شاهد يعني خلال تاريخه مثل هذه
الحالات يعني عن صراعات بين جماعات
العسكريه ثم بعد ذلك جاءت مصالحه بعد
التدخل عده اطراف ربما الداخليه اقليميه
ودولي كذلك ممكن اليوم بين البرهان وحميد
انا انا اتحدث عن عدم المصالحه في الوقت
القريب الراهنه يعني اعتقد ان الان ما في
ما في نفوس الرجلين بعد ما جرى من
الحمامات الدماء بعد ما جرى من تقريب
للمؤسسات
السياديه ومحيط
التي يعني
القائم عليها الدوله كلها الان تعرضت
للتقريب اعتقد انه في الوقت القريب هذا
يعني تبدو المصالحه بعيده ما لم يرد
الرجلان والزراء الى ما هو اسوا
وان يقدم التنازلات هذا هو
المرجو وهذا هو المامول كذلك حتى هذه
المصالحه تتم لا بد من اراده اقليميه
ودوليه حقيقيه يعني نحن نسمع ونرى ان هناك
مبادرات على مستوى الوطن العربي على
المستوى الابتلي وعلى مستوى المجتمع
الدولي غد نشطت ومنجزات ومناسبات بضروره
ايقاف وقفه العضائيات ولكن لا نرى فعاليه
وحيويه لهذا لهذه كل المبادرات او كل ما
يطرح بضروره تهديه الاوضاع وفكي لماذا
لماذا لماذا
حتى الان لم تفلح اي جهود يعني في اختراق
هذه الازمه في وضع اي حلول بين هذه
الاطراف ونتحدث ربما عن الاطراف الاقليميه
الافريقيه العربيه المؤثره هذه الاتصالات
التي تجري خليجيا وكذلك امريكيا حتى
الان لماذا هي الضعيفه او غير قادره على
التاثير الان على اطراف
يعني
السبب الرئيسي في عدم دفعه والتقدم هذه
المبادرات نحو نحو الامام هو تصلب البرهان
في ذات المواق محاوله الانتصار للذات
محاوله الانتصار للمؤسزتين الاكبر القوات
المسلحه والدعم السريع هي كبار يجري الان
هو
معرفه وجوديه
لتلك المؤسستين وقبل ذلك للرجلين فبالتالي
يبدو هنا التهنج وعدم الرغبه في السماع
لاي صوت يمكن ان يدعوهم ويطلب منهما
لقاء البندقيه ولول
ا وفتح المجال امام تاديه وهذا ما نراه
الان خارج من خلال
التي يعني سادسه امس وقبل ان تبدا فشلت
وذلك من خلال تبادل الطرفين
الاشتباك والقتال يعني كيف راينا نحن
وربما اطلاق العربيه منذ الصباح الباكر
كانت تنقل
للمشاهدها يدور في محيط القياده والمدفعيه
السفينه التي استخدمت وسحب الدخان التي
حجبت احياء الخرطوم خاصه الاحياء الغربيه
فاذا عدم
فقدان الصيغه بان الرجلين وعدم رقبتهم
اي مبادره في الوقت الراهن هو واحد من
الاسباب الثانيه ربما يتعلق ايضا باسباب
او فنيه
مطابق خرطوم حيث انه كان ينبغي ان يصل
ثلاثه من رؤساء الى الخرطوم قبل 72 ساعه
ولكن
الملاحه غير صالحا فاذا الحل
ان يكون هناك
الحدود
وفيها
مخاطره امنيه لرؤساء
قد يخدم من الخارج في ظل اضطرابات امنيه
لا
ندري سلامه الوفود القادمه خاصه النفاق
الدبلوماسيه في داخل غط تعرضت
فهذا يجعل الامر في المحل فاذا الان تبدو
المباعده في المصالحه فرديه واقعيه
وموضوعيه في ضمن الظروف
الرائحه ولكن
هناك مبا السعوديه اعتقد ان وزير الخارجيه
اول
[موسيقى]
من زاد دعاهما الى وقت نزيف الدم والى
التهديه ولكن هذا الامر ايضا يحتاج الى
تعزيز وجودي يحتاج الى لقاء بين الرجلين
لاليات يحتاج الى لجنه تقوم وتجرف على
الاوضاع
يعني تثق فيه اتجاه
النفوس في الوقت الراهن هناك ايضا
المضاد بانها يقودها الرئيس السيسي مع
رئيس السودان الفقير
الازمه وم من الاتحاد الافريقي ومبادره
رابعه من الجامعه العربيه ولكن على ارض
الواقع السوداني نجد ونشاهد مزيد من
الدماء مزيد من البارود الذي يسكن الانوف
تماما ويحجب الرؤيه من خلال ما تنقله قناه
العربيه بهذا اللحظه من دخان متصاعد
سيد خالد فقط
للعربيه خدمه الكهرباء لا تزال متوقفه
بسبب اعطالنا يا جماعه الاشتباكات يقول
ايضا نعمل على التامين المرافق الحيويه
ومقرات وكالات الامم المتحده يقول ايضا
والي شمال دارفور ابلغنا الجيش والدعم
كذلك سريع
برفضنا استمرار القتال في الولايات في هذه
النقطه تحديدا سيد خالد الفكي
هناك بعض التقارير تتحدث عن امتداد او
خطوره امتداد هذا الصراع الى ولايات اخرى
يعني اليوم نتحدث عن تركز المعارك وان
المعارك هي المعركه الرئيسيه لها في
الخرطوم والمره ربما الخرطوم تشهد مثل هذه
المواجهات العسكريه منذ استقلالها في 56
يعني لكن لكن امتدادها الان يتم الحديث عن
دارفور عن كردفان ايضا في الجنوب الغربي
البلاد هناك عده تقارير دوليه تتحدث عن
اشتباكات ايضا على حدود الدوله مع ريتيريا
واثيوبيا
ما خطوره هذا الامر اذا كانت مثل هذه
التقرير صريحه الصحيحه واذا امتدت هذه
المواجهات الى هذه الولايات وغيرها
مخالفه حقيقيه
واحتمالات يعني يجب لفت الانتباه اليها هو
يعني ان هذا الصراع هو لن يكون بيعها من
الاحوال متمركز بين الجيش
او بين البرهان الحميديه في الخرطوم حول
السلطه د
ون في الولايات اخرى وربما يعني انطلقت
بلاد اخرى وبدات في هذا الامر شاهدنا ان
هناك هو كان سريع في عدد من الولايات قالت
على مطارات وفرق الجيش سواء كان في شمال
دارفور الفاجر كان انه سيطره على مطار
الشهيد الصبير وعلى الفرقه في الفاجر وان
تبدا الامر كذلك الى جانبيه
يعني قرى او محليات اخرى عمود اخرى عفوا
في دارفور
له مراهق
الاحتجاج والاحتشاد المضاد الذي
تحدث عن الحديث
وهذا المسلحه بعدتهم في امتداد هذا الصلاح
ولكن
من يملك ضمانات ما هي الضمانات لعدم يعني
انضمام كل طرف
الى ومحاوله
سنه الدخان ايضا التي تتصاعد الان وتغطي
اجزاء كبيره من سماء العاصمه والسودانيه
الخرطوم
واشتباكات ايضا ومواجهات مستمره في اكثر
من محور
وخاصه في محيط القصر الجمهوري وكذلك في
محيط مقر القياده العامه ومناطق ايضا اخرى
متفرقه العاصمه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الخرطوم
بجامعه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يتشاركه هو البرهان وحماتي على مدى
السنوات الماضيه افسدته رصاصه خرجت منذ
اربعه ايام من قلب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم لتتحول بعدها البلاد الى ساحه حرب
يديرها من كان يعد بحمايتها حليف الامس
بات عدو اليوم
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدارفور اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم
تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي تقاتل فيها
قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي افريقيا كان في
جنوب السودان وقتل حينها حوالي 400 الف
شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع استقرار جارتها
الشماليه وما يدور حاليا فيه قد ينتهي فقط
بفوز احدهم في المعركه مع عدم استبعاد حرب
اهليه طويله الامد قد تجر جيرانها وفق
صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه
ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه في ان
قوات الدعم السريع تدعم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه فيما اخبر البرهان الصحيفه
الغربيه انه بمجرد اكمال الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده الى التكنات
وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام 2023
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
عد الى متابعه هذه الصور الان ايضا من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم نشاهد هذه
الالسنه من الدخان التي تتصاعد وتغطي
اجزاء كبيره من العاصمه السودانيه في
المناطق متفرقه ايضا من الخرطوم
ونشاهد هذه الصور الان التي تظهر ربما حجم
المعارك والعمليات القتاليه التي تشهدها
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه السودانيه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي عمار
عوض كيف تعلق ولنعل هذه الصوره سيد عمار
نعم
الصور التي تظهر واضح انه
او ردموه حول استكتاب في وظيفه او بتعلف
فاعل
تنكر الوقود الخاص بالطائرات في المطار
الخرطوم هو الذي ابطى ذلك المشهد
على
المشهد العام او الذي يصدر للمشاهدين لكن
بالعموم وامكان تبقى لي اعتقد عشر دقائق
لنهايه هذه النشره ساقول كل ما لدي
بتسلسل معين الوضع الانساني نعم الهدنه لم
تنجح واضح انه ليس هنالك رغبه او ليس
هنالك سيطره من احد الاطراف على القوات
التي تدفع له وهنا اعني قوات الدعم السريع
النقطه الاخرى تتعلق بالخبره
النقطه الثالثه تتعلق بعدم وجود مراقبين
لتنفيذ هذه الهدنه او
اليهود بتحديد علامات الاعلام علامات هذا
الاسعاف غيره الطرق الامنه الوضع الانساني
هنالك فيه تدهور كبير اذا كان في
المستشفيات واحده من المشاكل الاساسيه انه
خروج التيار الكهربائي كثيرا عن مناطق
التي تدور فيها العمليات في الجنوب عدم
وجود غدره للانداد مما اخرج حواليه 53
هنالك حياه مواطنين معرضه للخطر في
الاحتلال التي تقع شرق المطار والاحياء
التي تقع قرب المسار وهنالك نقطه اساسيه
في هذه المعارك هي الاسر التي موجوده في
محيط منزل السيد محمد حمدان وهي النقطه
الجنوبيه الشعبيه من
القياده العامه
والمتاسمه لخط المطار توجد بها اسر
في الجيش في البحث السريع
يعتقد كثيرون انهم يتم استخدامهم كدروع
هذه النقطه هي التي يتم انطلاق الهجمات
منها على القياده في الجانب القياده
العامه في الجانب الجنوبي وعلى المطار حيث
انها كانت مربوطه بطريقه سيربط منزل محمد
حمدان هذه المطار تتحرك في هذه المنطقه
الدعم السريع تقلق كل هذا الذي يحدث في
محيط القياده العامه ولا يمكن التعامل
معها كما يقول قاده الجيش لان ذلك يعرف
حياه الاسر بما في ذلك شريط المنازل الذي
يتبع لاسات جامعه القرطوم في الوقت نفسه
اعتقد انهم يزان القوى على الارض
يبدو انه ان كل الاطراف يحاول ان يجعل
ميزان القوى لصالحه استمتع العام لتغيرات
ميزان القوى تتحرك الاغوات الجيش السوداني
للحد من المعسكرات الكبيره التي تتبع
للدعم السريع والان انتقلت للمعثرات
الصغيره التي كانت توجد فيها قوات قوات
المدرعات وغيره تم استهداف ذلك في الشجره
تم استهداف ايضا
المنزله في مدينه جبره الذي يعدى قاعده
عسكريه تم تحديد عدد من القواعد لهذه
المواجهات في ضوء هذا الوضع الضبابي
الغامض ربما الان الحسم ولمن ام التجميد
اعتقد انه الوضع سيظل هكذا يوم او يومين
لكن انا ما كنت اقوله حول الشمس المتعلق
بتغيير موازين القوى هو الذي سيعطينا نظره
تخيليه للمستقبل وهذا ما كنت اقوله الدخول
قوات كبيره من الجيش السوداني بالمناطق
متفرقه تحاول ان تصل الى الخرطوم
يبدو ان الجيش السوداني يستخدم سياسه
الانهاك او سياسه الاستنزاف نسبه لان قوات
الدعم السريع ليس لديها ما يعرف في قواعد
امداد او سلاسل همداد مكتمله اذا كان من
الذخيره او اذا كان من الوقود هو لا يحاول
ان يستهلكته يحاول ان يجعل هذا ما يظهر لي
على اقل تقدير يحاول ان يستهلك الوقود
والذخيره الموجوده لدى قوات الدعم السريع
لاطول فتره ممكنه ثم يبدا فيما يبدو
المرحله الثانيه قسمت العام لتغيير ميزان
القوه بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع نحن كنا
هنا في مدينه ام درمان شاهدتها اكثر من
حوالي 60 عربه قالوا ان هذه العربات هي
الذين كانوا عليها قالوا انهم اتون من
المعارك التي تدور في منطقه مروي هو يحاول
ايضا ان يعزز وجوده الجيش يتحدث عن دعمي
من دول اقليميه ويبدو ان الاشاره الى
ليبيا او الى شرق ليبيا تحديدا وحيث تم
استهداف الرتلي من التيارات في تلك
المناطق
استمتع العام لتعديل موازين القوى بالنسبه
للدعم يظهر لي بانه يحاول ان يستولى او
يحاول ان يظهر
من الاماكن التي تعد استراتيجيه مثل القصر
الجمهوري او الصور التي يظهرها حول
القياده العامه او ربما يتم استهداف
وزارات وهذه الوزارات هي ليست يقول غاده
الجيش انها ليست قيمه في الوقت الحالي
باعتبار انه ليس هنالك جهاز الدوله يمكن
ان يتم ادارته من الفتره الجمهوري او من
الوزارات لذلك يعتبرون ان هذه المناطق
ليست ذات اهميه استراتيجيه في تغيير
موازين القوى او في تامين المنطقه القياده
العامه ان كل الاطراف الان والطرفين ليست
جاهزه للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات
لا كيف تعلو لاحد دون الاخر وبالتالي لا
مجال لاي وساطات حتى ولو كانت من خلال
مبادرات اقليميه الدوليه اليس كذلك السيد
عمار
نعم يبدو انها كل طرف لان لحظه دخول
الوصفات الدوليه ذلك يعني ان هنالك من
سيعطي الامان لهذه الطائرات يعني من الذي
يسيطر على المطار بالتالي الان كل الاتصال
من جنوب السودان من تشاد من الاتحاد
الافريقي من الولايات المتحده عبر لكن
يحاول ان يبقى في المطار لاطول فتره ممكنه
ليكون لديه
القدره على اتخاذ القرار بهبوط طائرات
المبعودين الدوليين لكن بالعموم اعتقد ان
هذه الاوضاع ربما تحسم في الايام الماضيه
او تدخل في هدنه
طويله في فتره العيد الذي يعد
سيد عمار عوض الكاتب الصحفي كنت معي من
الخرطوم
تغطيه ايضا مستمره زميل احمد الهادي يعود
اليكم مره اخرى على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات